us enjoying our time at home 24/7 a new
season of the hit series a good fight is
now streaming on CBS all access
Christine Baranski you know her play
Chicago lawyer Diane Lockhart the Emmy
and Tony winner originally took on the
role more than a decade ago in the
series The Good Wife in the season four
premiere of its spin-off Lockhart finds
herself in an alternate reality after
falling into a coma
it was president who yes oh I'll tell
you later
Diane are you micro dosing again no but
maybe I don't know isn't Trump president
know so it's yes how long has she been
three years you're right Dan
are you all right Diane hi Christine
Baranski going home can i good to see
you it's good to see you I know when I
was watching that episode I was thrown
to I was thrown to always good to see
you Christine because it's an alternate
reality where Hillary Clinton wins in
2016 election but there are so many
cultural references that I went huh haha
but you said this is your favorite
episode so far why it's the face that my
favorite episode that I've done in the
10 years I've played the character well
for one thing I think it's an extremely
funny and witty episode and I've done so
much comedy in my career but I don't get
to use those chops usually a playing
Diane who's such a serious legal
character but this you know this begs
the question what if Hillary had been
president and it opens up a lot of very
interesting issues and it's it's head
spinning because what if hundreds of
thousands of women hadn't marched in
Washington the day after the
inauguration what about that anger with
that anger have led to a me-too movement
would Harvey Weinstein still be you know
what he would he still be you know
functioning in the world and all those
other guys that came down as a result of
the me2 movements so it's a really
compelling episode but I also just think
it's damn funny it I was gonna say it's
compelling but it's also very funny and
there's a couple times that when I went
oh I winced a little bit I'll let people
watch that decide for themselves
I remember when when the show launched
in 2017 and you we had you on and you
were a little apprehensive because we
were thinking CBS all access how's this
going to work will we be able to find an
audience it goes to show you the
audience finds things that are good they
find it and that even a list stars want
to come and play like Michael Michael J
Fox who's back but talk about your
apprehensions they got how you're
feeling about it now well look where we
are
everybody's sitting at home and they're
looking for them they're looking for
good content and they certainly will
find it watching the good fight I still
you know I've always said this is the
only show that really places characters
in the world in which we are living in
the trump presidency and for all these
years we've you know had Diane you know
being a resistance fighter against Trump
and going crazy as a liberal feminist
living through this era and I think it's
you know the only show where you see
people living in this crazy era that
we're going through and so I think
people will relate to it strongly it's
it's you know it's relevant it's a very
relevant show you know obviously it
doesn't address this current health
crisis but we you know we got shut down
like the rest of the shows by mid-march
but I have no doubt that if we continue
that that the Kings will address this as
well Christine it's Anthony in the
trailer for this season you appear in a
leather cat suit which got your fans on
Twitter kind of excited to my question
is what did you think of their reaction
and more importantly what did you think
of the
catsuit you know there's there's only
one issue do I look good in a cat suit
and you know it's it was it was a brave
move and you know III hope I hope it
works I haven't seen I haven't seen the
episode but was it fun yeah it was fun
all that Pilates that I did I hope it
pays off and Christine you're a ward
winner
oh thank you Anthony Christine you're a
two-time Tony Award winner right now
Broadway is dark and and I want to just
what do you think the impact is going to
be on that sector of the economy on
those artists and on the fans who want
to be there it's it's just heartbreaking
I my heart goes out to my my fellow
actors and actresses there's so much
talent on Broadway the idea that they're
sitting home and their apartments and
and not able to exercise their talent
and may I also say we lost one of
America's great playwrights just as the
virus was beginning to take a toll he
was one of the first victims Terrence
McNally who who wrote about the AIDS
epidemic and you know I said it's a pity
the lights of Broadway will not dim for
Terrence because they are they are
already dark so you know I just my heart
goes out to these talented people I I
don't know where we're headed the fact
is none of us know where this is going
we're just all going there together and
the Broadway community in the theater
community that is one strong community
and we will survive we are survivors and
but my heart goes out to them yes
Christine last time I saw you you said
you know what I'm working harder than
I've ever been I feel better than I've
ever been and may I say looking at you
in that cat suit you look better than
you've ever been to so go you I'm a
little scared of you right now and you
know what I mean hold it up you bothered
ah I am
I'm not in a cat suit now but I'm I'm
home with I have three little grandsons
here in Connecticut with me and my
daughters I'm I'm very much active every
day playing soccer and baseball and and
you know keeping up with three little
boys so yeah you got to be in good
health to do that yeah I was going to
say none of us know how this is going to
turn out but we thank you so much for
taking the time Christine Baranski I
hope to be a grandmother one day what do
they call you Christine your
grandchildren what do they call you they
call me they call me Minnie Minnie for
Minnehaha because my late husband wanted
to be called Kemosabe okay long story
there but I am super happy thank you so
much